from yahoo news
they report quote the house voted
wednesday to censure representative paul
gosar after the arizona republican
posted a violent cartoon video that
depicted him killing representative
alexandria casa cortez and attacking
president body the resolution passed 223
to 207 with two republicans
representative liz cheney and adam
kissinger of course
uh joining all uh 221 democrats voting
in favor of gosar censure representative
dave joyce who sits on the house ethics
committee voted present
three republicans did not vote
the measure stripped gosar of his
committee assignments including a seat
on the house oversight committee a panel
which he had served on which he had
served alongside ocasio-cortez okay so
this is um what the house of
representatives concerned itself with
yesterday all right and and many
democrats took turns giving impassioned
speeches discussing in somber and and
firm tones the inexcusable violent
threatening dangerous terrible meme that
paul gosar retweeted
before we go any further
we should probably play that uh meme for
you
just so you understand what we're
talking about
it is a jokey video apparently made as a
as a parody based on some kind of anime
show i'm not familiar with the show
and uh it shows gosar as some kind of i
don't know action hero ninja or
something and at one point in the
cartoon well rather at one point a
cartoon with gosar's face attached hits
another guard cartoon
with aoc's face attached with a sword
okay very dangerous stuff
parental advisory stickers all over this
thing but let's uh let's just give it a
watch
[Music]
my god horrified
that's the worst thing i've ever seen in
my life
so while inflation skyrockets cargo
ships remain jammed in our ports drug
epidemic kills 100 000 americans a year
dozens of other very real crises grip
our nation congress spent the day
talking about uh this cartoon
and nancy pelosi kicked things off
shaking her head saying that this is a
sad day it's a sad sad day for congress
and she's right actually it is a very
sad day for congress but not for the
reason she thinks
and she continued by drawing a
connection to
what do you think she connected this to
you just take a guess january 6th of
course she said quote depictions of
violence can foment actual violence and
jeopardize the safety of elected
officials as witnessed in this chamber
on january 6 2021 it is inconceivable
that a member of our community would
wish to repeat the violence of that dark
day
now we're not going to test our
intestinal fortitude by playing too many
clips of these democrats sobbing over a
meme cartoon on twitter but we do have
to play at least i think we have to at
least suffer through a little bit of
aoc's remarks
because she after all was the victim uh
the quote unquote victim of this cartoon
and that is an udder that she is always
eager to milk and let's watch her do
that now
i've been serving in this body
just under three years
not three years
enormous amount has happened
but in response to
the republican leader's remarks when he
says that
this action is unprecedented
what i believe is unprecedented
is for a member of house leadership
of either party
to be unable to condemn
incitement of violence
against a member of this body
it is sad
it is a sad day
in which a member who leads a political
party in the united states of america
cannot bring
themselves to say
that issuing a depiction of murdering a
member of congress is wrong
and instead
decides to venture off into a tangent
about gas prices and inflation
what is so hard
what is so hard
about saying that this is wrong
this is not about me
this is not about representative gosar
but this is about what we are willing to
accept
this is not about me
this is not about me as i use the word
me and i
uh 72 times in my 10-minute speech about
me
you know we really can't on second
thought we should not be playing clips
of uh alexandria caves or cortez when we
are broadcasting from
you know the uh the sixth floor of a
hotel room when i'm right next to a
window because the urge to jump out is
sometimes overwhelming when i'm
listening to this person a sad sad day a
sad day an incitement of violence
democrats of course are not satisfied to
call the cartoon merely inappropriate or
crass or vulgar
no they have to make it into a terrorist
act they have to pretend that gosar was
actually threatening himself
he was himself threatening to stab aoc
with a sword or encouraging other sword
wielding assailants
this meme was actually a message to
gosar's team of secret ninjas calling on
them to finally launch their
long-planned attack
that's the way democrats tried to
present it and when most republicans
aside from the usual suspects cheney
kinzenger refused to join the censure
that sent them into even more furious
spasms of outrage aoc accused
republicans of nihilism
for uh not being angry enough about the
twitter meme
and all the democrats were very upset
pretending to be very upset anyway uh
the republicans would not would not join
would not join them in being that upset
but republicans were right of course to
not go along with this why i mean is it
because
congressmen ought to be
posting with anime memes you know is
that is that is that a is that a thing
ideally that we'd be doing no i mean it
doesn't bother me personally i think
it's kind of funny but in a perfect
world
it would not be unreasonable to say yeah
you know that's a little inappropriate
it's kind of crash and childish let's
not do that you know
yet in this world which is far from
perfect
even if you feel that way about the meme
you can't say it would democrats demand
that you say you can't bark on command
like a trained puppy because then you
are willfully participating in a charade
you are assuming a role in their stage
play
aoc called it nihilism the republicans
will not condemn
inappropriate behavior that's not what's
going on here
it's more that they are refusing to be a
part of the democrats nihilism
if the democrats in congress actually
cared about incitements of violence
and about crass and inappropriate
behavior by its members
and they condemned every such example
and they were so stringent about it so
respectful of the rules of decorum and
decency that they even made time to
condemn memes and cartoons right
if this was all in the context of them
being very consistent on this issue then
maybe you might give them a little bit
of what they want you might say sure
yeah you shouldn't opposed to that
but that's not how it works
their message is not that members of
congress should not incite violence
um not that paul gosar did inside vows
but that's not their message their
message the point they want republicans
to agree with
as they all clasp hands together is that
the rules should be applied based on
their ideological and political needs of
the moment
which is why for example when maxine
waters has repeatedly and explicitly
called for violence against her
political enemies or squad members
repeatedly and explicitly justify and
foment blm rioting
there's no condemnation there certainly
knows censure
because the rules are different for them
and anyone who will not agree that the
rules are different
is a nihilist they say
it's all quite grotesque and outrageous
which is why republicans need to do a
lot more than simply refuse to go along
with it that's a good first step so
there's a little bit of progress here
um because i think if this exact same
situation had occurred like five years
ago uh there probably would have been
you know 30 republicans joining
at least so they're not going along with
it that's good
but they should also be on the on the
offense
using the bully pulpit to call attention
to
behavior on the other side that often
goes far beyond memes and cartoons just
the latest example representative cory
bush like we talked about on the show
this week called the defendant in a
murder trial a white supremacist without
any evidence she's of course not the
only one to have done that
and also without evidence claim that
white supremacists shot at her in uh in
the streets of ferguson which we know is
a lie it never happened
why aren't republicans moving to censure
cory bush for that
sure they don't have the votes
but they can call for it
anyway two can play at that game but
only one ever does
i think it's time for that to change
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated